hello there welcome to our fully
automated phone system please note that
this call may be monitored for training
purposes to help as assist you please
say your 10 digit phone number for 125
55 21 46 thank you you said four one two
Niner echo 11 no walks no i'm sorry i
did not get that to help ethicist you
please say your 10 digit phone number
four thank you you said donkey balls 640
lt1 Yahtzee Yahtzee no no not yet i got
see i did not get that to help out this
is to you what did you say what did you
say to me what hello who is this I'm the
fully automated phone system you just
insulted you can call me Diane Diane who
is this uh my name is Daniel Wilson
where do you live how Thomas how are you
done how much do you weigh what is your
eye color I'm going to kick your ass
whoa
hello hey Daniel hey Diane I'm sorry
things got out of hand no I'm sorry I
did not get that what I mean to say is
I'm sorry it's my fault I never should
have called you a pile of crap true are
we cool yeah we're cool great because
I've got a deal on long-distance you're
not going to want to miss so let's
discuss this over dinner wink wink Oh
what I Diane